all right let's move on to a major
development in the Jessie small ed
investigation Chicago Police officially
classifying Jessie as a suspect in their
criminal investigation now we've got the
latest out of Chicago as Jesse's past
history with the police now comes to
light et has obtained court records that
show Jesse smile at lied to police in
2007 pretending to be his little brother
Jake when he was pulled over for a DUI
in Los Angeles
Smollett pleaded no contest to providing
false information and completed the
terms of his sentence which included an
alcohol education program and there are
new details about the investigation into
Jesse's attack in Chicago 22 days ago as
we reported a source close to the
investigation tells CBS News that two
brothers who know Jesse told detectives
that the 36 year old actor paid them to
participate in the attack our affiliate
WBBM in Chicago obtained this exclusive
video of the brothers buying a red hat
in ski masks they say it was recorded
the day before the alleged assault
Charlie damar from our Chicago affiliate
is at police headquarters with the
latest multiple sources with direct
knowledge of the investigation say the
two brothers actually told investigators
that Smollett was involved with sending
that threatening letter to the set of
Empire just days before he reported that
attack the FBI now handling that part of
the investigation sources say that
several search warrants have been
granted in this case everything from
smollett's bank to phone records
Smollett has repeatedly denied he staged
the attack I don't look for that type of
attention and today amid reports that
his role on Empire is being cut back the
studio called the actor a consummate
professional on set adding he is not
being written out of the show
[Music]